le verglas qui a tout enrobé à Montréal
le matin du 5 janvier a fait au moins un
heureux celui qui pilote les essais du
REM entre la Rive-Sud et la gare
centrale on a souhaité effectivement
faire rouler un véhicule et voir les
limites de ce de l'exploitation dans ces
conditions là et le train est tombé en
panne au bout d'environ 10 km après le
pont Champlain une fois que le fil est
recouvert de glace la glace agit comme
isolant et il y a perte de contact
électrique entre le fil qui conduit
l'électricité et le pantographe et les
équipes avaient fait exprès de ne pas
déglacer les caténaires selon le
protocole prévu qui consiste à faire
rouler des véhicules de manière
régulière pour justement empêcher
l'accumulation de glace sur le fil sur
le fil de contact et en plus de cela on
équipe certains véhicules pas tous d'un
grattoir
ce qui s'est passé à Ottawa avec six
jours d'interruption sur une partie du
réseau de train léger serait en partie
dû à une mauvaise gestion des véhicules
pendant l'épisode de verglas selon cette
expert et parce que la fréquence était
pas assez grande la glace était
accumulée et elle s'est accumulée à une
vitesse rapide et continue mais le
système automatisé du Remon réaliste
sera-t-il à l'abri de problèmes
similaires il est pas moins vulnérable
il est simplement plus flexible c'est à
dire que si vous devez aller chercher un
conducteur à minuit pour justement
répondre à un épisode de puverglaçante
c'est un petit peu plus compliqué que
d'appuyer sur trois quatre boutons pour
sortir un véhicule de la zone de remise
lors du test du 5 janvier le REM est
reparti après quelques minutes
d'immobilisation mais en cas de panne
prolongée il faudra se rabattre sur les
bus de Longueuil au risque de miner la
confiance des usagers si ça arrive trop
souvent mais on va voir aussi un réseau
de bus à Longueuil qui sera pas fiable
puis si finalement ni le ramener le
réseau de bus sont on va perdre des
usages et malheureusement l'ouverture de
la section arrive sud du REM a été
reportée à ce printemps après les tests
hivernaux ici Mathieu pros Radio-Canada
Montréal